to do something on her own in front of
all these people for the first time
she's never even been up on a stage and
practiced
so to see her up there my nerves are
just like
i honestly start crying kim kardashian
is
one proud mama she definitely has
kanye's outgoing personality
and then she's also really calm and
sweet like me sometimes
the reality star and her sister kourtney
kardashian
took their daughter's northwest and
penelope disick to paris
for kanye west's fashion show back in
march
and lucky for us keeping up cameras were
rolling and caught a then
six-year-old north totally slaying her
performance on stage
[Applause]
impressive right she nailed it i had no
idea what the fashion show was going to
look like in itself but then when kanye
asked nora i think do you want to sing i
just the nerves that i have now
right when they arrived kanye took north
backstage and set her up to rap
during the show naturally kim was super
nervous
and watched from the crowd doing what
moms do
filming the whole thing on her phone
beaming with pride
and getting a little teary-eyed i'm
happy for her but i'm so nervous for her
i'm so proud at how confident she is she
obviously gets that from her dad
and it just makes me so happy that she's
not afraid to try anything
that to me was so much fun to see you
know she's just so
fearless and i love that about her and
i'm such a proud mom
is it just me or is this giving you
major kris jenner circa 2007 vibes
kim you're doing amazing anyway
north's aunt was all about it too to see
north you know have no fear and just get
up there
and do that was really really cool and i
think it's safe to say
kim is a bona fide stage mom i am so
proud of you
i was like literally
oh my gosh my performer needs some water
of course
that's what i have for dad right off
stage yeah
kim even admitted it herself oh my god i
was like crying
like
[Music]
and back in march right after the big
performance
kim shared a little sneak peek behind
the scenes as northey celebrated with
her mom and dad
oh
okay so it looks like the apple didn't
fall far from the musical tree
i mean she's even showed off her moves
at her dad's sunday service
like she's down for anything but when it
comes to north following in her parents
showbiz footsteps her mom told et
there's no pressure i hope that they
just find their own motivation and no
matter what that is no matter what they
want to do in life i hope that they work
really hard i think they have good
example i i learned from seeing both of
my parents work really hard
and i think our kids will see you know
kanye and i work really hard
and i hope that's motivating for them
and just to find their own path they
think
to not pressure but to definitely have
our
[Music]
rules